hey there guys gals in non-binary pals
this is chef and author kenji lopez alt
and i'm here to answer your cooking
questions on twitter this is cooking
support
[Music]
dollars more asks what's the difference
of cooking chinese food with a wok than
your regular frying or saucepan all
right so the main difference between a
frying pan a western style frying pan
like this and a wok
is obviously the shape so the way a wok
heats up you're going to get a really
hot zone in the center down here where
it's closest to the flame and then it's
going to get progressively cooler a
western style frying pan on the other
hand all of this is meant to be sort of
relatively evenly heated so you don't
get those cooking zones in a western
skillet you're going to be shaking
around and when you shake around like
this when you're sauteing something the
food naturally forms a sort of even
layer and it cooks evenly and that's
really good for sort of sweating
vegetables the things that you might do
at the beginning of a soup or a sauce or
a stock something like that whereas in a
wok when you shake it they obviously all
fall down to the bottom so you don't get
an even layer however in a walk
the shape allows you to really
efficiently get food moving through the
air and that's the process you're going
to be doing when you're stir-frying the
majority of the time so that's the
difference between a wok and a western
skillet at truevisuals asks what's with
asparagus and stinky pea asparagus
contains these sulfur compounds that
some people can digest and some people
cannot it's estimated that about 20 to
50 percent of people cannot digest these
sulfur compounds and for those of us
which includes me if you eat asparagus
about 15 minutes later go pee and your
pee is going to smell like these sulfur
compounds so there's a very distinct
asparagus piece now now this gets
confounded by the fact that there are
also some people who can smell these
compounds and some people who can't tane
mclean says how do you ruin a good
burger so personally there's a few
things i like to avoid when i'm making a
burger i don't like adding things inside
the burger so i don't like adding egg
crumbs or eggs or spices or seasonings i
feel when you do that it turns it more
into a sort of meatloaf what i associate
with a meatloaf texture and flavor so
either just pure ground beef i do like
to have it plenty fatty so you know
something around 25 to 30 fat in my
burger that's what i want i want it nice
and salty whether it's going to be thick
or thin i want it to have a nice deeply
browned crust there are some people who
like steamed burgers it's a thing but
please don't steam my burger
at haitian soul asks does anybody know
how to butcher a whole chicken meat i
know how to butcher chicken um so i'll
show you right here so why would you
want to butcher a whole chicken it'll
save you money it's cheaper to buy a
whole chicken than to buy the individual
parts it also gives you lots of tasty
things like the backbones and the
carcass you'll use those to make stocks
that are better than what you could buy
in a box we're going to first take off
the legs there's this little flap of
skin that stretches out all you got to
do is kind of nick that with a sharp
knife just like that and do the same
thing
on the other side just give it a little
nick get your thumbs in there and twist
them
until the joints pop out now you hold it
by one leg with the chicken kind of
hanging down and then what you want to
do is you want to get your knife in here
and right here is a little nugget of
meat called the oyster you want that to
come with you you don't want it to stay
on the carcass because it's tasty all
right so we're going to try as much as
possible to get our knife down into
there and then we just go
through the joint which we just popped
out and then you have your leg same
thing on the other side make sure we get
the oyster
look for
the articulation the place where the the
two joints meet right there now you want
to get your knife right in that slot
and just cut through all of this should
be pretty easy if you feel yourself
forcing it then you're you've hit the
bone and you want to reset i like to
leave my chicken breasts with the uh the
skin on and bone in typically when i'm
cooking them so the way i do that is
first i take this wing off twist the
chicken around
until you've cut all the meat around
that wing and your knife is in contact
with the bone the whole way so we see
some bare bone here and flip it like
that and it pops right off and you have
this nice exposed bone which is going to
look really pretty when you cook it and
then you can get the whole chicken wing
with the drumette and the flat attached
okay and now for your chicken breast and
you cut down into the ribs
and this is the only place where you're
going to be cutting through bones the
ribs are pretty easy to cut through
though all right and you go all the way
down
this inside out the wishbone's going to
pop right out like that there's your
chicken back you can chop that up to
make stock with split the chicken right
down the sternum
and there you've got a bone-in
skin on
chicken breast for cooking and then if
you do want to remove the chicken breast
from the carcass what you're going to do
is run the tip of your knife basically
along one side of the sternum the meat
should separate pretty easily run your
thumb along the meat and pull it away
from that connective tissue
and then just finish it off with your
knife and then you've got your boneless
chicken breast and that is how you
butcher a chicken
at joshna maharaja asks hey peeps doing
some research how do you get really
crispy skin on your roast chicken to get
really crispy chicken skin there's a few
steps you have to take what i like to do
is spatchcock it so i cut out the
backbone with a pair of scissors you can
ask the butcher to do it for you also
then you can lay it out flat so you get
all this surface area exposure to the
heat of the oven finally the other thing
i like to do is i season it with a
mixture of kosher salt and baking powder
mix it up in a bowl sprinkle it all over
your chicken what happens is the baking
powder will react with some of the
juices that are coming out of the
chicken skin and those juices are really
rich in protein and they form these
teeny tiny bubbles that as they
dehydrate they add surface area and
therefore extra crunch to your chicken
skin
i didn't know that radiation is also one
of the heat transfer methods for food
how the hell radiation cooks food
all right so there are three basic types
of heat transfer um whether you're
talking about food or anything there is
conduction that's when i touch a hot
metal pan and the heat is going directly
from the metal surface there is
convection which is when the heat is
transferred through a medium such as
flowing air or flowing water and then
there's radiation when you don't need
any kind of contact at all the most
common form of radiation you're probably
going to find in your cooking is when
you're baking something in the oven an
oven cooks through a combination of
convection in the air and infrared
radiation directly from the oven walls
so whenever you're cooking over coals or
under a broiler the type of heating that
you're doing is radiation it's direct
heat energy coming from the heat source
through the vacuum of space or through
the air as it were at worst make asks
tell me hank what constitutes a pinch of
oregano a smidge of basil and what is
salting to taste whose taste what kind
of taste so if somebody says a pinch of
oregano or a pinch of cumin i would
think that it's about this about a
sixteenth of a teaspoon or so but if you
love oregano you love cumin put more of
it in it doesn't really matter the one
case where it does matter is with salt
because salt can have a severe impact on
the way foods cook because it chemically
interacts with meats it chemically
interacts with a bunch of different
things but with salt typically what
you're looking for is around a one to
two percent ratio of salt to other stuff
in each given bite so if i have a soup i
can weigh out the soup and i can add one
percent of that weight in salt and it
will taste relatively well seasoned to
most people at earl m asks does anyone
want to know how the sausages are made
well that's an easy question i want to
know how the sausage is made um i
started a sausage restaurant in san
mateo so i have a good deal of knowledge
about how sausage is made so yes
sausages have this reputation of being
sort of lower quality meat they're made
out of scraps i think that's good it's a
way to use up all the different parts of
the animals they are just meat fat
seasonings importantly salt and then
they are stuffed into casings so in a
sausage
there are a few elements so when you cut
open a sausage what you're going to see
is a few things first there's going to
be the meat sausages are often made from
pork shoulder the lean meat that's going
to be the sort of darker colored parts
you're going to see the fat which are
these sort of creamier white parts you
might see little specks in there and
those are going to be the sort of spices
that you're adding to flavor it finally
the most important element that you
won't see with your eye is the salt you
cannot make a sausage without salt what
happens is when you mix ground meat with
salt and you start kneading it the salt
will dissolve some of the mussel
proteins and it allows them to stick
together and it forms this protein
matrix so salt and meat is what gives a
sausage structure the casings are
typically
made out of pig intestines if you get a
big great big salami that's probably a
cow intestine and if you're getting a
natural casing hot dog that is a lamb
intestine yes nothing to be afraid of
great way to use up all the different
parts of the animal and delicious at
baby chumps says why do eggs make normal
food taste better burgers ramen more
eggs put an egg on that ho
and call it a meal if you think about it
an egg is a thing that contains all the
nutrients a growing embryo needs so it's
extremely nutrient dense and our bodies
are hardwired to like foods that are
nutrient dense that's why eggs taste so
delicious it's as simple as that so we
taste it and we think yum this is good
at the scramble asks question for you
how often do you sharpen your knives and
how do you do it i sharpen my knives
probably once every six months or so i
like to use water stones this one is a
thousand and six thousand the lower the
number the grittier it is so i typically
start with eight hundred to a thousand
or so and then go up to around six
thousand so from the cutting edge to the
back and divide that by three and what
you wanna do is maintain that angle the
entire time you're sharpening i go in
one direction for about 20 strokes or so
and by that point the metal gets pushed
up and it curls over the edge of the
knife i should feel a bur on that side
then you can flip the knife over and
start working on the other side and so
i'll start with 20 on each side until i
feel the bar on both sides then i'll go
down to 10 on each side then i'll go
down to something like four then two and
then i'll do a bunch of single strokes
and once that's all done i'll move over
to a higher grit stone so that's the
basic process of sharpening a knife at
dennis n dairy 2 underscore asks what is
myoglobin what is the function of
myoglobin myoglobin is a pigment that
makes our muscles red so when you look
at a steak and you say oh it's still
bloody that's actually not blood that
you're seeing giving it the color it's
myoglobin which is muscle pigment now
with some modern meat manufacturers what
they sometimes do is that if you buy
vacuum sealed meat in those pouches
it'll look very bright red and what
they've done is they've injected that
pouch with carbon monoxide and when
carbon monoxide reacts with myoglobin it
turns into carboxymyoglobin there's a
smith going around that the food
industry is dyeing meat red to make it
look more appealing to customers they're
not literally dyeing it red they're just
kind of maintaining that red color and
what may be a sneaky underhanded manner
but it's not going to affect the quality
of the meat elaine gruder says anyone
recommend me a good cooking wok what i
would recommend for a home cook is a
flat bottom wok there's a bunch of
materials you can choose from carbon
steel is the best for a walk because
it's inexpensive it's indestructible you
can raise it to a really high
temperature so here's another walk we
have here so this
is a non-stick wok so nonstick would be
the material i would be least likely to
recommend because nonstick cannot be
heated to the temperatures required for
certain types of stir fries what happens
is if you heat up non-stick the coating
will start to vaporize and it's really
unhealthy to breathe in so non-stick
walks i would stay away from them at
kaiila says why is angel hair pasta so
damn sticky for something angelic it
sure is a pain in the ass angel hair in
particular is going to be very sticky
because for a given volume of pasta
because it's so skinny you're going to
have a very high amount of surface area
so the more surface area you have the
more starch is going to come out the
more surfaces there are to stick to each
other in order to keep pasta from
sticking you do want to get and get it
into a sufficient volume of water that
you can get it moving right from the
start so the the main time when pasta is
going to stick together is right at the
beginning as it's starting to cook so
you want to make sure that your pasta is
moving right at the beginning once it
starts moving and boiling and setting
and softening you're not going to it's
not really going to stick as much at
ciao oyimbo nyash asks can someone
please help me how do you make fried
rice i could explain it but i will just
show you instead you don't need any
specific type of rice the most important
part is that it is dry take a little bit
of corn starch
sprinkle it over and that's going to
help you break up the individual grains
of rice i recommend a wok so you want to
preheat it over really high heat you
want everything to go really hot and
fast i've got a couple eggs scrambled
them with just a little pinch of salt
and get them right in there
i'm gonna cook them just until they're
set
and then out they go into a bowl we have
waiting on the side all right so now i'm
going to reheat my wok and start working
on my rice
and the goal here is to really try and
sort of separate the grains without
turning them into one big pile of mush
so you can see i'm using the back of the
spatula here to kind of push them
against the wok and keep them moving all
the time
over the highest heat possible instead
of cooking all the rice at once if you
have a really weak burner cook it in two
different batches and then we'll add
everything back in at the end walk
smoking hot a little bit more oil in the
center onions are going to go in carrots
are going to go in some of these frozen
peas are going to go in
i'm going to add some garlic
a little pinch of scallions
[Music]
now finally everything is going to go
back in so the rice
and the eggs
now what we'll do is we'll use our
spatula to break those eggs up
so that we get a nice even distribution
soy sauce around the edge
sesame oil it's important to add your
sauces around the edge when you're
cooking in a wok like this because what
happens is if you add them directly to
the center they kind of trickle down
through the food so they don't really
sear whereas if you add them around the
edge you can see they give that nice
sizzle right when you add them and what
that does is it reduces the soy sauce
rapidly and kind of introduces new
flavors gives a little bit of smoky
flavor that's basically it shall we try
it
delicious so the big takeaways are make
sure that your rice is dry before you
start cooking with it cook hot cook in
batches and cook fast and that's
basically it lunatic destiny asks why
would you use baking soda while cooking
baking soda is a powdered
alkaline when you take baking soda like
this and you add vinegar to it it's
going to form carbon dioxide
and water
that's what gives your cakes and your
pancakes and cookies lift right it's a
chemical leavener so you can take baking
soda put it in water and boil western
style
pasta and it will give it a sort of
springiness and a flavor very similar to
eastern style things like ramen you can
take baking soda boil your potatoes what
happens is the uh the higher ph makes it
so that the pectin on the surface of the
potato that's sort of the carbohydrate
glue that holds the potato cells
together the pectin breaks down faster
and so you end up with potatoes that are
softer on the exterior so that when you
subsequently toss them and roast them
they get a lot more surface area they
make them extra crispy and finally you
can add baking soda to your beans if
you're planning on making a bean soup or
you want them to tenderize faster so i
add baking soda to the water when i'm
making something like hummus and i'm
cooking the chickpeas because it'll cook
chickpeas much much faster at ren harker
asks what is so difficult about cooking
pork to a safe temperature maybe your
parents generation or your grandparents
generation there was this time when pork
was relatively unsafe to eat at raw or
rare temperatures because of the risk of
a parasitic infection called trichinosis
that has been almost completely
eliminated in modern pork so it's not
really something you have to worry about
so a lot of modern pork has very very
lean meat and therefore it becomes
harder to cook and keep juicy because
lean meat dries out a lot faster without
the fat and the connective tissue to
keep it moist so with pork what i
generally recommend the best way to cook
it to a safe temperature and make it
stay juicy is to brine it so if you have
a pork chop you put it in a in a
solution of about two percent salt two
to three percent salt in water or you
can just sprinkle it with salt and let
it sit in your fridge overnight and then
when you cook it the next day what
happens is that salt breaks down the
muscle protein so that as they cook they
don't actually constrict as much they
don't squeeze out as much moisture as
far as safe cooking temperatures for
pork versus beef versus chicken the
government will recommend that you take
them all to 165 degrees fahrenheit which
is the temperature at which
you get a seven log reduction in
bacteria that is only one out of every
10 million bacteria will survive with
most meats i actually recommend cooking
to a lower temperature things like steak
are tastier at around 130 degrees i
think just when the fat starts to render
out and things like pork and chicken i
generally cook to about 145 or 150
degrees but essentially at 165 degrees
it takes less than a second for that to
occur whereas at about 150 degrees it
takes a matter of minutes so as long as
you're taking your temperature carefully
and you're coming up to a specific
temperature and letting it rest at that
temperature before serving it you can
get the same sort of safety level even
at lower temperatures atrianati asks why
is it so difficult to make perfect rice
it's either too soggy sticky or too hard
help me depending on the type of rice
you're using you're going to need a
different water to rice ratio with
something like a japanese sushi style
rice which is what i cook most it's
about 1.1 times water to one part of
rice i'll measure out my rice put it in
the pot then i'll measure out 1.1 times
that volume of rice put it into the pot
start it cold put a flame underneath it
bring it up to a simmer put the lid on
it turn the heat down to the lowest
possible setting and let it simmer at
that temperature for about 10 minutes
don't open it up don't look at it
definitely definitely do not stir it if
you start stirring it what happens is
you release all this excess starch and
that's why your rice starts to break and
turn mushy after 10 minutes shut the
flame off and let it sit for another 10
to 15 minutes to completely absorb all
that liquid and then finally if you were
patient and you didn't touch anything
when you open it up you should have
perfect rice so those are all the
questions for today thank you so much i
love it when people ask questions like
this because it means you're thinking
and you're using your brain while you're
cooking and you're not just following
the recipe you're trying to get out
there and experiment and i love that
thanks for watching cooking support
[Music]